hello everyone and welcome to what's
definitely one of the weirder things
that have happened since I'm covering
games on this channel it's a game uh
from around three of the match Johnny
bonus versus Wesley so in the official
random World Championship where the
current uh official random world
champion Wesley so loses a game uh uh
basically because he doesn't know the
rules of official random chess it's
quite incredible and uh he was a
completely weirded out by this after the
game he discussed it with Jan and he
wasn't even sure if the move was
possible and then when it turned out
that the move was not possible he just
resigned the game now I've spoiled it a
bit but it doesn't really matter because
it's a extremely short game uh the game
basically ends as soon as something
starts happening so I'm just gonna show
it to you uh I I really can't remember
the last time something like this
happened so basically Jan had the white
pieces this is the third game first game
was very nicely won by Wesley danyan
retaliated in the second one and now
this is the third game so yeah you know
very very important stuff being played
here as both of them are trying to catch
up to satro who is just destroying
everyone and only two players will
advance uh but yeah let's let's see what
happened here Pawn to see four Bayan we
have Pawn to B5 by Wesley trying to open
up his Queen uh C5 advancing the pawn
not allowing the B file to open up and
now Pawn to E5 we have Pawn to B4 Bion
uh and pawn to D6 now challenging the C5
Pawn uh with Bishop to B3 very nice
diagonal for the bishop now as the king
is in G8 and now Pawn to A5 repairing A4
and uh get rid of the Bishop from this
diagonal so A3 freeing up the A2 Square
for the bishop we have Bishop to F6 and
now uh Pawn to E3 we have Knight to E7
and now Pawn to F4 challenging the E5
Pony One open up the bishop and your
Rook on F1 Ponte E4 blocking this and
now we have a trade but first seat
captures on d6c captures Knight the E2
and only now Bishop captures on A1 Queen
capture so not much Happening Here
Knight to F6 nicely developing Knight
the C2 and now Rook the C8 we have a
knight seat the D4 an excellent Square
for this Knight a captain B for a
captures and now Bishop to D5 this
bishop is a monster so of course you
have to counter it Bishop to D5 in here
Jan trades Bishop captures on D5 you
could also play Rook to B1 and uh not
capture improve the position of your
pieces a little bit but he decides to go
for captures we have Knight E captures
on D5 and now Knight to F5 and this is
where things start to get tricky uh
Wesley can never move the Knight on F6
as he will get checkmated on G7 so here
he goes Rook to C2 of course he improves
the position of his uh his pieces once
again and the B4 Pawn is hanging but you
can never capture it because then even
Knight to E7 check will just win for y
to win material that's enough so Rook
the C2 by Wesley and not Knight eat the
G3 another very tricky move now kind of
giving up the D2 Pawn but if you capture
the D2 Pawn then Knight captures an E4
becomes a possibility like we said the
Knight on F6 cannot move because of
Checkmate and uh not there on G7 so
instead after Knight eat the G3 Queen to
C8 by Wesley and doubling up on the C
file and also inviting Knight captures
on D6 to attack the Knight and even
though Queen to C8 is perfectly fine for
Black Knight captures on D6 Bayonne and
now uh what wisely should do is play
Queen to d8 this is how he gains counter
play and then after some captures happen
on the E4 Square captures captures
captures on e4 he can just castle
kingside and everything is perfectly
fine however Hereafter Knight the d8
Wesley played Queen to E6 and here the
unimaginable happens Yan plays Queen to
A8 with check and here Wesley stops and
uh he discusses with Yan if he can
Castle here block check and the attack
is Queen and they really discussed this
during the game and Jan even talked
about it in an interview after the game
he he said that I mean as far as he
knows uh that it should not be possible
and then Wesley just resigned here as
his plan really was after Queen the A8
check he wanted the castle bring the
Rook over here block check and attack
White's Queen which is uh just
incredible so now not only does Wesley
loses the game here but what's uh I mean
what I can't uh comprehend not even a
little bit is that how is this possible
I mean how can the world or the reigning
world champion of anything like really
anything be unfamiliar with the rules
and it's and it's not like it's some
sort of a you know offbeat rules that
applies in maybe one in one million
games this is uh you cannot uh I mean
you cannot Castle while in check that's
that the most Elementary rule rule there
is in chess so I have no idea what
happened here we did not get to see an
interview with Wesley I'm sure there
will be one at some point uh but uh you
know as soon as we we learned something
I will inform you guys uh very very
weird stuff this is like this could be
the weirdest thing that happened over
the board uh since I'm covering games
um you know about about Chess uh so yeah
if you guys have any insight on this do
share your your thoughts in the comment
section uh but otherwise this is I mean
incredible he he really wanted the
castle after Queen the A8 to check he
wanted the castle here that's I'm I'm
without words uh but yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it and I mean
at least you have a nice story to share
with your friends at the bar in the
library I'm sure they will enjoy it
greatly if they are not following the
the world Fisher random Championship so
you know uh give give my best regards to
them uh so yeah that's the game hope you
hope you guys enjoyed it and learned
something new that it doesn't matter the
variant uh you cannot Castle while in
check I would like to thank uh
subramanian John shirtleff
Morrow and Johanna for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this fine
event uh until it uh until it finishes
so thank you all I will see you soon and
uh have an excellent rest of your day